vous allez donc 28 ans et alors ça s'est
fait de revoir les l'interview qui vous
inquiétez pas non mais on a on a
l'habitude dans cette émission on gère
les rires ont géré les pleurs ça va bien
ouais merci en tout cas d'être là non
franchement des très content de vous
avoir
et d'après vous restera avec nous on va
rigoler sur plein de trucs et où
j'espère qu'on va vous détendre d'accord
ça fait d'être et sinon merci d'être là
alors vous faites actuellement 10 à
cause d'un grâce à l'interview que vous
avez donnée à hugo clément / combiné
news où vous dites donc avoir été
harcelés et menacés
c'est vrai que nous ici dans l'équipe ça
nous a vraiment touché récemment et
notamment l'équipe rédactionnelle mais
aussi l'équipe des chroniqueurs vous
êtes victime de harcèlement sur les
réseaux et sur les réseaux et dans la
rue aussi ses sables sur les réseaux
c'est vrai que c'est sans cesse et
expliquez nous ce qui se passe en fait
en fait je dénonce donc l'harcèlement
depuis très longtemps
ouais bien avant balanced ont peur etc
je dénonce le fait d'être harcelée sur
les réseaux sociaux c'est une chose mais
dans la rue c'est ça je vais parce que
les courses je vais faire mes courses on
insulte de tous les noms mais qu'est ce
qu'on vous dit pourquoi parce que vous
êtes une ancienne actrice porno parce
que vous êtes une actrice porno donc
vous insulte ou vous dit quoi ça a pas
fait que le csa ou non vous inquiétez
pas non mais on n'est pas dans une benne
on me dit ouais j'ai le souvenir c'était
cinq mecs dans une voiture je faisais
mes courses et un après midi avec mon
petit caddie et tranquillement et là
j'entends unique
mais tellement fort que tout le monde
entend tout le monde entend ça se passe
quand chèque avec mon compagnon bien sûr
voir s'effacer beaulieu mais ça va reste
très très fort et me soutient totalement
dans me soutient toujours
voilà après à l'harcèlement sur les
réseaux sociaux qui est ultra ultra
violent c'est en ce sens vous n'y allez
plus vous allez encore sur les réseaux
sociaux ou par givet dans le sens où si
demain je vais me déconnecte de tout
sans que ce soit un choix personnel mais
si je me déconnecte à cause de ça voudra
dire que les gens gagnent et pour moi ce
serait serait une soumission en fait
d'accord je peux pas que vous
l'affrontez voilà ce qui se dit vous et
et vous voulez voir voilà ce qui vous
aussi vous voulez pas vous didot dire
voilà je quittais réseaux sociaux parce
que ça serait bien de ce rendez vous
avez gagné le main les linges à main il
ya un quartier qui est un peu compliqué
on diagne nana va pas dans ce quartier
c'est un peu chaud donc elle va pas y
aller à cause de ça ça peut paraître
bête parce que c'est que des réseaux
sociaux mais pour moi c'est un sens dans
le jeu n'est pas à me retirer à cause
d'eux alors de personnes qui menacent
qui harcèlent donc dans l'interview
d'hugo clément le moment le plus
poignant c'est aussi le moment où vous
dites ne pas vouloir faire d'enfant
parce que vous avez peur pour pour votre
enfant et qui qu'ils soient victimes de
2-2-2 voilà vous fait une victime
collatérale de ce qui vous arrive
[Musique]
on attend vous inquiétez pas on rend
l'antenne qu'on trouve il n'ya pas il ya
pascal après c'est tout faire un enfant
c'était mon seul rêve dans ma vie
c'était celui là j'avais je ne rêve pas
d'avoir d'argent je rêve pas de gloire
je me fous tout ça moi c'était voilà
faire un enfant lui inculquer de deux
merveilleuses valeur de lui donner
tellement d'amour que je sais qu'il
aurait manqué de rien pour avoir renoncé
pour avoir renoncé vous avez 28 ans vous
avez le temps oui oui il faut lier
franches à ce que si ça ne tenait qu'à
moi j'en frein il comprendrait au moment
venu je vais expliquerai avec son père
bien sûr voilà maman elle a un passé ça
n'empêche pas que maman et elle mais
avec maman elle a une morale mais au vu
de moi qu'on
je suis détruite par les réseaux sociaux
clara morgane quand elle a annoncé sa
grossesse c'est eh oui bon on va pouvoir
lui dire fils de [ __ ] ça va être tout le
temps tout temps comme ça il ya sur les
sur les réseaux il ya aussi à l'école il
faut il faut passer au delà de ça vous
aimez vous viviez venez vous viviez pas
à travers les raisonnements envie d'être
maman je lui faut que je voie les mamans
mon enfant il est des séquelles je ne je
me l'interdis je veux pas je veux pas
qu'ils souffrent aussi toit après
expertise n'a pas besoin de faire du duo
pour faire des enfants chez sa mère et
d'autres d'autres parents qui ne font
pas ce que vous avez fait oui mais si on
est gamin et les maltraitent donc mais
ça c'est des parents d'un enfant quoi
que vous allez changer d'avis et je
pense que vous devriez changer d'avis du
ce sur les chemins de la ville n'avait
que 28 ans et je suis persuadé que voilà
que vous allez avoir un enfant un jour
et qui sera très heureux à vos côtés ça
j'en suis sûr et sa propre bière 15 ans
après genève le redresser
tout le monde se sent mieux celle de
valérie non car c'est bien valérie
tellement elle concerne tout le monde
oui mais contacté les parents justement
quel est le message du coup vous qui
vous a demandé
ouais ça les sirops posé la question
cette gamme passage de votre interview
que je trouve formidable c'est vous pas
entre autres vous parlez des enfants et
des enfants mineurs en disant je te
souhaite recontacter l'entente pour leur
dire faites attention quand même à ce
que regardent votre enfant il est est ce
qu'il est en âge de regarder ça vraiment
fait attention à ce que vous le savez
non mais jamais ça sert mais est-ce que
vous conseilleriez à des jeunes filles
ou des shows nomme de faire des films
peau des films pornos ou pas du tout 7
ce qu'il ya une différence de traitement
entre les hommes et les femmes
sexiste même temps le mignon c'est que
les harmonies c'est des bons coups c'est
bezina les fils et des traînées siffredi
est considéré comme un dieu c'est ça il
attend c'est fou donc pour les jeunes
filles il ya aussi beaucoup d'acteurs
pour nous qui ont très mal fini
malheureusement il ya eu beaucoup de
celui-ci dans ce milieu là faut pas
occulter sa part contre juste une chose
concernant tout ce qui est suicidé que
c'est faux bien comprendre une chose
c'est pas le porn en lui-même qui
détruit les actrices ou les acteurs ce
n'est pas le porno il ya des ya des
filles qui le jardin d'autres moins bien
dans ces cas là tu vas voir une
psychothérapeute penser mais voilà c'est
comme le
enfin vous il ya les moments voilà en
germe gérer un petit peu moins bien mais
c'est pas c'est pas le nom c'est moi
c'est le csa vous êtes en train de dire
qu'il va détruire c'est important de le
répéter que ce n'est pas le truc des
filles c'est la société c'est ça c'est
cet achat le regard des autres c'est le
regard des autres le fait qu'on peut
même pas se reconvertir alors qu'on n'a
rien commis d'illégal
non mais c'est à des meurtres et 1,1
quelqu un qui arrête ya purgé 20 ans de
prison
demain il peut se reconvertir mais vous
il ya toujours cette vous êtes toujours
marqué comme vous avez parlé de clara
morgane
voilà qui est très heureuse a maintenant
clara voilà mais c'est vrai que voilà
c'est une hypocrisie totale parce que
malheureusement ceux qui regardent pas
de film x
il vous connaissent pas c'est donc ce
qui vous un succès ceux qui ont regardé
tout ça quoi oui mais très courte mais
plus d'un point de vue sociologique c
est ce que je sais pas de quand vous
avez arrêté de faire du porno deux ans à
deux ans est-ce que vous avez
l'impression qu'aujourd'hui que sur les
réseaux ou dans la rue s'il ya beaucoup
plus de haine est beaucoup plus insultes
aujourd'hui qui pouvait la voir avant
oui on est d'accord il y en a beaucoup
plus et d'ailleurs quand mathieu des
fois intervenu sur les réseaux sociaux
fin la violence moi je le comprends
totalement parce que à force de se faire
taper dessus tout temps tout le temps
tout le temps faim reste des êtres
humains quoi bien sûr si vous avez
arrêté là complètement de quoi ça leur
nombre est complètement on fait quoi
maintenant
mais pas me dire je peux pas le dire
parce que c'est illégal ya eu des
problèmes d'accord non non non neuf
jours où je veux me reconvertir fin vous
aimeriez faire quoi je me suis vite la
discrimination est en fait je ferais
éventuellement une à peu près une future
collègue de pascal pas grande force à la
trouver non c'est pas vrai quoi vous
êtes si ça vous ne pas dire précisément
mai
n'ont pas d'enfant parce que ça crée
roscanvel une ex actrice qui s'occupe
des oeuvres sacrées ans quand elle met
d'accord vous êtes 500 à dos sur nrj12 à
qui va arriver là vous allez faire de la
télé nikita n'ont pas le droit pas de
dater mais dans le même mois on va très
bien et bah écoutez ça vous plaît
totalement c'est vrai que vous êtes
heureuse la wii après ce qui est
compliqué c'est voilà là la
discrimination qu'on subit
quotidiennement par exemple pour la
reconversion c'est moi c'est un métier
c'est un métier j'ai toutes les qualités
pour le faire c'est je suis très
travailleuse formant dire tu te
réveilles à 5 heures du matin j'y suis
il n'y a pas d'arrêt maladie je suis
quelqu'un qui aime qui aiment travail
voilà donc par exemple c'est un métier
qui pourrait pas faire jean michel maire
ça c'est fait mais voilà on ne subit la
discrimination et ça faut que ça change
il me semble que marianne chapier
d'ailleurs arrêts prévus combien
exactement à la halle à el al a réagi à
la régie à cette interview et bien moi
je vais vous dire la seule chose que
j'espère que vous allez faire si vous
allez changer d'avis et vous allez
décider d'avoir un enfant parce que ma
confiture vous serez une mère formidable
vous n'avait que 28 ans est-ce que je
vous faire un gros bisou
[Applaudissements]